alors là on a une grande surface de 11
m² de miroir et tous les miroirs
viennent concentrer les rayons du soleil
jusque dans la partie basse du four
[Musique]
et au niveau du four on attend une
température de 900 degrés
hop
là on va peut fourrer il y a 270
nous une heure de soleil le four est
chaud et après c'est 40 kg de pain par
heure voilà donc vous comptez en hiver
si vous avez 4 heures de soleil vous
sortez 120 kilos de pain en été si vous
avez 12 heures de soleil comme ça nous
arrive en Normandie il faut compter mais
ça fait beaucoup de temps
[Musique]
donc là on est quasiment bon
encore deux trois tranches de devant
et si on accepte pas de repenser nos
organisations de repenser nos schémas
culturels nos modèles énergétiques nos
représentations nos savoir-faire etc
jamais on peut réussir à essayer de
travailler avec un fort solaire jamais
on va réussir à questionner ces
pratiques pour pouvoir s'y adapter au
mieux
[Musique]
on remplace 20% du café par des graines
locales ça dynamise l'agriculture locale
ça réduit les transports internationaux
ça limite la déforestation et on peut le
torréfier au solaire même en Normandie
donc il y a un potentiel vraiment
incroyable
[Musique]